time then for the press preview a first
look at wednesday's
front pages and tonight we'll see what
is making the headlines with the crime
correspondent and columnist with the
belfast telegraph alison morris and the
chief political correspondent
at the daily telegraph christopher hope
very good evening to both of you we
shall chat in a moment first of all
let's check out those front pages
for you why don't we begin with the
metro writing that
deaths linked to covid 19 have dropped
by 97
since the peak of the second wave in
january with a quarter of adults
now fully vaccinated here's your ft
leading with a story about china
expecting to record its first population
decline
since the disastrous great leap forward
policy was introduced in the late 50s
sir james dyson has accused the bbc of a
grotesque mischaracterization of his
links to the tory party he says
his texts with the prime minister are
not inappropriate that's according to
the telegraph
on the front of the eye number 10
refuses to deny boris johnson said he
would rather let coronavirus rip
that imp than impose another lockdown
briefed families say the comments are
like twisting a knife the guardian leads
with the continuing row about the source
of the funds for the renovation of his
downing street flat
with the prime minister being urged to
come clean
now motorists will be able to check
their emails and watch tv
and the plans to legalize driverless
cars by the end of the year
that's according to the daily mail
june olay days ole ole days i think
that's it isn't it
uk tourists can travel to spain from
june with a digital health pass
after discussions between the two
governments says
the sun very poor spanish
now we're joined tonight by the belfast
telegraphs crime correspondent and
economist
alison morris and also chief political
correspondent at the daily telegraph
christopher hope to have a look through
wednesday's front pages
um alison why don't we start with you
front page of the
eye anger at prime minister over let it
rip outburst on covid
i mean this seems to be never-ending
doesn't it the prime minister under fire
from many different
directions hear the eye saying that
families of those who've lost lost loved
ones understandably
are furious and the prime minister
hasn't denied he made these comments
although he
has denied making the other comments
that were revealed this week
yeah and i think that's probably the
most interesting thing about this is
that we
know what was reported earlier in the
week we know that there's a lot of
briefing going on
against the prime minister at this time
which is interesting given the fact that
conservatives are so far ahead in the
polls but is it a good idea at this time
to sort of for anyone to launch a
leadership challenge or disable
the leadership of the party but at the
same time that he's not coming out
and denying these would lead you to
believe that someone somewhere a capital
receipts and has evidence that these
comments were actually made
and he knows if he denies them it will
just get worse and he'll be proven to be
a liar somewhere down the line so you
imagine that he's gonna have to
say something soon but what i have found
interesting i think about this week is
that we can see that his one-time
trusted
colleague dominic cummings has clearly
still kept a lot of his contacts that he
had
in the press this is the man who we know
used all his powers to get boris johnson
into downing street in the first place
is he able to use those powers to get
him back out of downing street again you
know i think and we're all watching
carefully to see
what else is going to be revealed in the
next few days
well christopher tomorrow will be
fascinating won't it prime minister's
questions
of course as always on a wednesday kia
stammer will want the prime minister
to uh publicly uh deny that phrase
certainly the body's
piling high line it's going to be a very
tricky time for him at the dispatch box
i'm really struck by the language here
because this term
let it rip was a was often used
by the tory the government front bench
against people who wanted to try
and lift lock down were resisting
the government's attempt to shut down
and i remember vividly
i think i think it was mark harper who
leads the coburg recovery group the
leading lockdown skeptic
being accused by a government minister
of wanting to let it rip
and he got really really crossed by this
language he said that was never his view
this term was clearly a term which was
doing the rounds
inside and outside government and i'm
fascinated that
the pm apparently had said this it just
to all this just shows to me
that the um the formal inquiry into what
happened
over the kobit 19 response cannot come
soon enough and i'm told
it is not for months and because of this
delay because of the need to learn from
mistakes
because the government is refusing to
look at these mistakes
these headlines will keep on coming and
i think
this inquiry has to start soon
okay um alison let's turn to the metro
then um we've already heard about boris
johnson under uh
under scrutiny over what he's been
saying about second lockdown also under
scrutiny of course
over the flat refurbishment cash for
cushions as somebody
on twitter called it today which i
thought was quite clever the headline
the metro has gone for boris under
the hammer and the pressure continues to
mount over this
yeah and going by the the pictures that
we have seen it was cash for some fairly
horrendous looking cushions you know i
think that
the fact is that this is something that
there will be a paper trail of so this
is something
that the prime minister cannot deny if
public money
was found to do this refurbishment does
has been claimed he's not going to be
able to cover that up with this late
date
we know that the spending of that money
will have been logged and will have been
monitored and i think that all of these
things coming at the time that they are
are no accident i think that we're
seeing a shift i think we're seeing a
shift within the conservative party
it was always i think the the suspicion
of some that boris johnson was going to
be put in place until brexit was done
and then maybe replaced with somebody
else is that what we're saying here
i'm not sure but what i do know is that
there is a terrible lot of briefing
going on to the press in relation to
the inner workings of downing street as
a journalist i find it fascinating you
know
blake's coming out of out of a house of
government i'm always in favor of keep
it coming i want to know what else has
been going on this is public money the
purchase of the public interest
it's not taxpayers money alison is it
it's not tax payer sorry to interrupt
but it's not taxpayers money
um uh if anything it's a tory party
uh donor um uh lending this money um
if that is what it turns out to be do
you think
the taxpayers the electorate actually
care that much well i do think there has
to be open
openness and transparency in relation to
political donations because we've seen
the abuse of political
donations in the past and in terms of of
people doing favors so you say do you
think that the public want to know i
think that they're deeply interested
in this story but i do think that really
if we're talking about what's more
important
is the declaration of the flat more
important than what actually went on
in the run-up to the pandemic and in
relation to the lockdown no the two
things aren't equal
in terms of importance we know that what
christopher said is right that
if there is going to be a public inquiry
into this it has to be take place
quickly
it also has to conclude quickly i come
from northern ireland a lot of public
inquiries and i can assure you we've had
public inquiries here
they have dragged on for sometimes years
and in the end people
didn't necessarily get the outcome that
they wanted they can be very expensive
costly and timely processes so i think
it's important that this one gets to the
heart of what has been going on very
quickly
but i do think that there's clearly
issues um in relation to
boris johnson's behavior and his
behavior while he's been in downing
street i think that that's the thing
that people are most interested in yeah
i mean
yeah yeah i just want to say let's get
we've got to go to the break in a minute
but let's get christopher's thoughts on
that because
there are lots of different threads
aren't there and it does all come down
essentially to the integrity the ethics
and and i guess the conduct of the prime
minister
well i spent the day in hartlepool ahead
of the by-election next thursday and i
just don't think
a lot of this stuff is cutting through a
lot of these red wall voters who
vote tori because they like boris
johnson don't really
kind of understand it i think this story
is the one which is a problem because
the denial that the toy party put out
today
was that the tory party funds are not
being used for this
uh doing up of the flat in number 10.
the question is
whether they were used and that wasn't
really made clear um and i think you
know and that means there might be a
benefit to boris johnson it wasn't
declared there for a breach i think it
could be a bit technical
um but it could be a problem for boris
johnson this is where he's under threat
at the moment
not on these stray comments will be
upsetting
comments but not these comments about uh
about covert
okay very interesting uh do stay with us
plenty more to come
alison and christopher thank you for now
coming up james dyson
breaks his silence over that text
message exchange
you'll remember with the prime minister
discussing that in a couple minutes
welcome back part two of the press
preview still with me uh alison
and christopher christopher why don't
you start seeing it's the daily
telegraph
front page uh dyson has been giving his
side of the whole
text messaging saga and
sticking the knife into the bbc why
don't you just remind us
what this is all about yes so so
we remember that we look last week uh it
emerged through bbc
uh reporting that james dyson had sent
texts the prime minister
remember there's a big push on for
ventilators last year
and he then uh sent texts to the prime
minister and they're revealed by the bbc
um asking about um if his staff came
back to the uk of course many
many of them work overseas i think in
malaysia if they gain back to the uk
um would that affect their tax status
he's an employee employer of the staff
of course um so i think that's not in
dispute that he sent the text
but what he's upset about is is to be
called um
um a big supporter of the conservative
party it turns out he's only ever given
5 000 pounds in 2016 and 6400
pounds um to michelle donald a tory mp
and his contention which is right given
that is it's hardly
of of the magnitude of other big
supporters you can give millions of
pounds and he says
that trying to paint him as a prominent
donor to get favors is not fair because
he was merely
someone employing people at a time of
crisis looking out for that for their
their
their welfare and contacting someone
senior in government so
he's concerned about being called a tory
supporter when he wasn't really one
yeah alison he's saying that um he did
send the text but what he certainly
wasn't trying to do was get any favors
yeah yeah and it's it's it's a great
story but i have to say
by the telegraph you know it's it's a
good skit because we were all i
mean i think i was interested in the bbc
story and this highlights i suppose what
we were talking about earlier
the importance that there is openness
and transparency in relation to
political donations to political parties
um
but i mean we do know that when we move
back to the start of the pandemic that
all sorts of
contracts were being handed out without
the proper attendant process that would
have usually
been essential for any any um hunting
out of government money so it's
it's right and proper that this is
scrutinized i think it's written proper
that as the
broadcaster bbc scrutinized it but i do
think that it's good that um jason has
come back and tried and put the record
straight
because any any public inquiry into what
went on at the start of brexit i will
look at these contracts and the fact
that he said i did not
um get any personal gain from this i
don't think he did provide any
ventilators at the end
they stand to be corrected if i'm wrong
on that but i think it's right you know
that he comes out and sets a record
straight but that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't be scrutinizing other
contracts and other favors that were
handed out
during that time because we know that
billions of pounds of public money was
handed out without the usual proper and
correct process and that's fine
okay christopher you wanted to come back
in and i i'm just going to get you to do
that before we move on quickly
i think i just think it's about unfair
to to judge all these different text
messages going back over a year when
you know people were dying and i think
officials and ministers were desperate
to try and save lives they were pulling
in favors across the board
it eventually led to a very good
vaccines program and i think
to have the whole picture again
presented by an inquiry
would give a context these little bits
of stories that can be damaging
yeah of course that's uh yeah and that
is the the government's defense uh of
course uh front page of the daily mail
allison self-drive cars in the uk
this year yeah i'm not sure i'm in favor
of this i'm not sure why this is
actually on the front page of the daily
mail either given
the the amount of you know really hard
news that's knocking around at the
minute i think if you notice if anyone
reads
this story before they get all excited
and think that they can you know
um watch tv on their way to work in the
morning while in their car they should
get to the last paragraph where
it says the two people in texas died um
in one of these cars last year so
um i don't think that we're quite there
yet as much as we'd all like to think
that we live in in some sort of you know
autumnized future where we won't
actually have to change gear
um anymore i think you know that the
technology probably needs of course
just another little bit yeah of course
you don't have to change gear in an
electric car do you there aren't any
gears
christopher just finished with this uh
great story uh it's been around doing
the rounds today
uh the pictures in the metro of tony
blair's
hair he's gone from mullet unbelievable
i mean
unbelievable i mean can we ever pause
for blair's hair and say nothing for
about a minute looking just look at the
hair it's
wondrous like a waterfall it reminds me
of sea
freedom roy those are those las vegas
performers i mean i mean you know to
grow that hair is he's put some effort
into it he's probably washing it
carefully each morning conditioning i'm
looking at him
it takes him back to his pop star roots
look at that look at this little picture
there when he when he was
at oxford university and he was in a pop
band i mean he's doing his best to
relive his youth
yeah maybe uh maybe a ponytail or an
alice band next who knows so alison
christopher thank you both very much
we'll see you again about half an hour